okay the david pakman show subreddit is
a really great place for people to
discuss politics we've just staffed up
and added another moderator to make sure
that the riffraff is at a minimum and
that the political discussion and debate
is respectful you can find the subreddit
at david pakman.com slash read it that's
our e DD IT a couple of interesting
posts that I saw this morning when I was
browsing the subreddit an interesting
comment from one user who says why are
so many progressives acting like not
wanting to abolish private insurance is
some sort of horrendous establishment
position yeah I think that this is an
interesting thing to discuss and it's
important for progressives not to focus
on the wrong thing I don't think it is
necessary as a part of the plan to
drastically improve the way health care
works in the United States to outlaw or
abolish private for-profit insurance
companies I say allowed them to exist
but make them irrelevant or unnecessary
for almost all people and what I mean by
that is that most countries that have
universal coverage systems or almost
universal coverage systems whether the
health care delivery method is
nationalized like in the UK whether it's
a more Medicare for All or single-payer
type system Canada Germany France all of
these systems are different for-profit
private insurance for the most part is
allowed to exist and if people feel as
though what they are getting from the
government subsidized funded managed
system is not good enough and they have
the money and they think it's worth it
go ahead and get yourself private
insurance that you pay for so I think
that this is not an area that
progressive you know when when Bernie
was asked recently I think it was Bernie
so you want to get rid of private
insurance companies and he says yes yes
I do I think it's fine to say we want to
get rid of them in the sense that they
should be completely unnecessary and
extraneous and we should have a
situation where no one would go and pay
for for-profit private insurance but my
pref
would be create a system in which the
government is involved that is a
nonprofit system that ensures almost
universal if not completely universal
coverage and then let for-profit private
insurance compete if they want for the
dollars for people who aren't satisfied
with the government system regulate
private insurance properly and that's it
I think it's a good point that's made we
don't have to advocate for the outlawing
of private insurance let's just make it
unnecessary irrelevant and extraneous
also from the david pakman show
subreddit a very much upvoted thread
about david should interview center
former Senator Mike Gravel and I have
exciting potentially exciting news for
you which is that Mike Gravel who is
running for president in 2020 former
senator really interesting guy has
agreed to an interview on the program
now we're trying to work out the details
and it's working out to be a little bit
more difficult than maybe we imagined to
finalize the details with Mike Ravel but
he has agreed to the interview and I
hope that we can make it happen so that
stay tuned upcoming and lastly a post
suggesting that the way the Democratic
National Committee will rig the 2020
primary will be to say you know what
there are just a lot of candidates and
we need to really gets to ultimately
decide who the nominee is going to be I
listen I understand based on what
happened in 2016 why there would be a
lot of skepticism or potentially even
fear that the DNC is going to quote rig
the 2020 primary I totally get it
call me naive I think that the way the
DNC could rig the primary at this point
would be by getting behind someone in a
relatively public way I don't know that
it's going to happen in the
behind-closed-doors
sort of shadowy way that some people are
suggesting I hope I'm not wrong and if
I'm proven wrong then I will tell you I
was wrong and that is exactly how it
went down
but I I think and believe based on what
happened in 2016 that we are going to
see a cleaner Democratic primary
although it's never completely clean and
we already are starting to get a sense
of who are the sort of establishment
picks but I hope that this person is is
not correct in their suggestion join the
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t one of todays sponsors is privacy comm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
i've actually been using myself for a
while now and i love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy coms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below